[Music]
first man starring Ryan Gosling follows
Neil Armstrong's journey to become the
first person to ever walk on the moon
no spoilers but we all know how it turns
out but how did the filmmakers recreate
the moon landing this is nathan Crowley
he's the movie's production designer he
told us how he made a trip to space seem
real how he actually staged the moon
landing and how he managed to fit an
entire rocket ship inside a soundstage
in Atlanta a production designer manages
and designs just about everything
physical you see in front of a camera
except for costumes Crowley has a lot of
experience with space and flight
everything in your toolbox you've got to
use before walking on the moon they
first had to get there Gosling rides in
a variety of spacecraft in the movie
Crowley built the lunar module and space
capsule to scale meanwhile the Saturn 5
model is only 14 feet tall about 125th
the size of the actual rocket yet it
looks exactly like it some of the models
could actually move the backdrop
meanwhile showed a rough image of what
would be happening during the scene
during some scenes this could help
actors get a better sense of what they
were acting against in real time Crowley
and the crew had ample historical
details to draw upon to bring the story
to life one of the most complicated sets
to design where the cockpits knows all
these codes so they have to be exact in
the sequential way that the alarms would
go on an even harder thing to make
convincing floating in zero gravity it
involves some ingenuity some parts of
the zero gravity sequences in first man
involved wire work in other parts they
put the camera on the ground and film
from below to give the appearance of
being suspended in the air this was a
technique Stanley Kubrick pioneered on
the set of 2001 a Space Odyssey
which was made long before CGI Crowley
is all about finding a perfect balance
between CGI and practical effects I have
a fondness for doing things practically
until you come that's a practical design
to immerse the audience in I believe
strongly that a mercy audience you have
to convince them that they're not
looking at fakery so to do that you have
to mix your mediums and make it as
complex as possible and go unnoticed so
basically they need to live in perfect
harmony with one another and while much
attention was paid to how the nasa crew
got to space the movie also had to nail
the actual moon landing a lot of movie
set in space will use natural scenery
for planets the Martian used the Wadi
Rum desert in Jordan in place of Mars an
interstellar used Iceland for its ice
planet scenes we made this film in
Atlanta Georgia and anyone who knows
Georgia knows it's pretty green down
there so not an ideal stand-in for a
grey rocky surface some parts were shot
in a nearby quarry to best capture the
horizon line other parts of the moon
landing were done on a soundstage where
they lit it in just the right way to
capture the moon's from each shadows and
design there's no fixing it later you go
to plan it figure it out and then do it
and if during that journey you get
something more interesting because you
hadn't foreseen something then that
Hoss is the film and in a year when
everyone seems to be thinking about the
moon-landing we went to the moon in 1969
audiences will be taking an extra close
look at first man the true are of
production design is for the audience
not to notice the design and just to be
in the store
[Music]
you